i had one of the most embarrassing
experiences with madonna
um
i was at the oscars i presented it went
well you know i went out afterwards to
sort of celebrate and have a good time i
probably had one too many and i was at
this party
uh with a couple of my friends
and um
an old friend of mine who's a manager
comes up to me and he's like tom tom tom
do you know madonna
and i'm like funny enough no
so he goes come with me come with me
come with me so he drags me across this
nightclub and introduces me to madonna
now the whole way on the way over there
i'm going what do i say hello
i had no idea what to say
so i get up there and i go
hello
that's all i've come up with i was like
hi i'm madonna how you doing i'm good
thank you i'm well and jason can see me
panicking
and goes madonna um tom is an incredible
dancer
and i'm looking at him like i'mma kill
you
and
she goes really well that's something
i'd love to see show me
so i'm thinking i have two options right
i can just faint
you know just pass out or i can take
madonna into the dance floor dance with
her and show her my moves and just have
a great time sure
you know me being an idiot i went for
option two yes so i take your hand and i
sort of drag her into the dance floor
and as soon as i took her i realized
that this was a mistake
it was a big mistake now i used to be
billy elliot and i used to do a lot of
dancing but that was all choreographed
you know i didn't wing it i didn't go on
stage and do a different show every
night
so i start dancing with her and and
there's not much arms involved i'm just
sort of doing a little two-step to try
and like warm myself up and she's so
unimpressed
she's so unimpressed that i just bailed
and left
i just can't do
the next day
i'm telling my family on facetime who's
having a family dinner about my evening
and the oscars they wanted to know all
the goss and i end up telling them the
story my dad is wetting himself my mum
is cringing and then my little brother
paddy goes who's madonna
[Applause]
not bad we're getting there
that's they're good aren't they yeah
she's cute yeah yeah thank you where did
you see that one yeah which of that one
yeah that one
the detail i think is amazing you kind
of made me look like a victoria's secret
model thanks
but here's the kicker um because when we
said we'd like to see your dolls and
they were coming especially to the show
they then especially for us
they made this
this is you
at the venice film festival there you
are at the venice film festival
well you don't have the glasses mario
and gianna you left the sunglasses oh
you have them okay look at that isn't
that good wow
[Applause]
do i get to keep any of those
but the other one is the only way to
have you at my home
when you were in a punk band uh
the the punk band was in uh atlanta
georgia okay when i started out but in
uh madonna stuff that was new york in
the early 80s and was she like a fan of
yours
uh no she was a fan of no one's but
madonna's yeah
she's she's only a fan of hers yeah
and still today still today
didn't you audition for madonna benedict
oh god yes i said
um and uh
yeah i i yeah she just sort of came in
breezily very late and uh had a
clipboard in hand said yeah
benedict cumberbatch is that really your
name and i mean yes it is madonna
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i didn't get the part
earlier in the year we saw you at the
super bowl yeah uh with madonna uh which
was
the most watched television program in
america ever yeah
isn't that incredible
[Applause]
um and did she text you or send flowers
when you knocked her off number one
she um she had nice things she emailed
me and said nice things yeah some nice
things yeah yeah well done whatever
yeah hope you're around in 50 years
like that when mcdonald's not you at all
but very exciting of course because you
got to make out with her
i didn't
really call that making out with her i
mean she kissed me
you kissed her
i didn't kiss her
you actually have the picture
no i got it on my phone
[Music]
and you had all those incredible
celebrities and you know star cameos and
things because i mean you were in scenes
with madonna which and she didn't even
know who i was
that's what that is i heard that is that
true it's true that's true or me so she
came in and she came in late to the
first read through she kept her
sunglasses on and she sat down and she
sort of talked like that i think it was
sort of a vaguely sacramento accent i'm
not sure
said i'm so not sorry i'm like
and then she started reading the script
and at one point she said listen jack
what
which one's jack and sean and sean went
hi hi sean hayes played jack mcfarland
hi hi and so at the end of the week and
most of her scenes were with megan but
every day she went to deborah and to i
and she said i'm sorry i don't remember
your name
and finally i was like this was when she
was really into kabbalah
and i said oh um i'm rocco
[Applause]
and she went wow
that's my kabbalah name and i was like
how about that
and literally for the rest of the week
she called me rocco
and that night we always have a
tradition where we hug and kiss each
other right before we go on and i and he
said okay he said have a good show deb
and madonna turned to him and was like
her name's not deb her name
and that's when he informed her that my
name was deborah and the next day after
the whole
episode was over i got six dozen roses
that said dear deborah thank you for a
great week madonna so i yeah so i the
same thing on the friday we've been
working personally for three days she
said i'm sorry i remember i said
this is the third time i said no my name
is so easy to remember it's the one at
the very very beginning of every single
episode of the show you're on and since
oh sorry so same thing i got a giant box
of roses with a card that i just found
the other day i thought i'd lost it
which said if my husband would let me i
tattoo your name on my arm love madonna
so i always forgive you all's forgiven
well
my thing
you've opened up a rift
our thing was
have you seen pictures of madonna lately
it's got rocco right there
i've heard you talk about how some of
your kids
don't really care so much that you know
their mother's madonna i think i think
they wish i wasn't okay i think they
would wish i wasn't the famous their
famous mother but do some of the kids
get a kick out of doing madonna yeah
but the younger ones yeah they enjoy it
but as you get older you know there's
peer pressure and you start to care
about what people say and think and
there's something called social media
yes you know that terrible dragon that
flies over everyone yeah and takes over
their lives
um and that affects my older children
obviously so they never say it to me but
i can i can tell
because my you know my son is is an
artist and my daughter's is a as a
dancer and i think
probably
um it would be less
challenging in their own mind for them
if they didn't have me as a
mother
well as a bar for success you've set it
quite high
cause i danced with madonna that's what
i hear
so how does that did you ask her did she
ask you no i mean i'm i'm 32 i i was
like
eight nine you know when she was like
virgining and doing all that and i was i
was crazy about her
and uh so you know
somebody came up to me and this was like
the fourth party like four o'clock in
the morning and said do you want to meet
madonna and i was like
yes
[Laughter]
[Music]
she was like wearing a hat and looking
super hot and she didn't even say hi she
just kind of like nodded at me and
started dancing well that's creepy and
it's nothing and then that must have
weirded you out not even at how long it
was not creepy
it was something else it worked
it worked for me if i did that if i went
up to just a girl
i wouldn't
can do things that no one else can do
and so so she's nodding and dancing
starts dancing with me i'm drunk enough
that i'm just going with it dancing and
then
she's like a crazy good dancer and i i
danced with her for like i don't know 30
seconds or something and then she just
lost me and and i and she kind of
started dancing with other people and
like
two girlfriends were with me that night
and they kind of ran over and they were
like you were just dancing with madonna
and we were talking about it for a
minute and we look over and my husband
is totally dancing
and i'm totally handling it
and
um way better than i did and i kind of
thought
like what's better than that no sarah
folsom you attended the met color and
apparently there was an odd moment with
the paparazzi yeah what i'm talking
about yeah i do yeah um uh no one was
taking my picture
and uh
and i was like wow oh my god i guess i'm
uh wow okay and uh
no one was taking it was like pictures
pictures pictures and pictures of this
one and i was like hello hello
nobody cared what were you wearing i was
wearing something nice
[Applause]
i turned around and all of a sudden i
saw madonna was standing there and that
everyone was taking her picture but
someone happened to snap my picture when
i first saw her
and that was unattractive
[Music]
and then madonna that was like the only
saving grayson just sort of made it
worse this is the moment that sarah
paulson noticed it was madonna cider on
the red carpet
uh
[Music]